jetzt droht das großes brot aus der
pfanne
doch bisschen
normal
mai zusammen heute gibt es ein richtig
leckeres pfannen brot mit käse ich habe
nämlich gedacht okay ich habe so ein
kleines hündchen aber wenig zutaten aber
auch nicht so große lust jetzt was
aufwendiges zu machen wir machen jetzt
einfach was schnelles und einfaches ich
schreibe euch wie man alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben und in infobox und ich
lege direkt los wir brauchen eine
schüssel da gehen wir magerquark mit
rein sind auch nicht viele zutaten die
wir heute benötigen er könnte zum
beispiel auch quark mit einer höheren
stufe nehmen das ist bei dem rezept gar
kein problem also 20 prozent 40 prozent
ist alles möglich da gebe ich mir mit
dazu backpulver ein bisschen salz und
olivenöl und dann verknetet das alles
miteinander
[Musik]
so fertig ist auch schon der teig es
ging echt super schnell ihr dürft euch
nicht wundern dass der hier so ein paar
risse hat das ist ganz normal und jetzt
teilen wir ihnen in sechs gleichmäßig
große teile ich mache das jetzt so
nehmen einfach meine teig karte können
es auch voll zu einer wurst formen das
ist ein bisschen einfacher sowie zweimal
durch teil und dann machen wir es so als
habe ich nur fünf raus ich morgen
nochmal ein sechster dazu ihr müsst es
auch nicht so genau nehmen das wetter
sowieso in der pfanne zubereitet und
nicht im ofen dann macht ihr so dass ihr
immer ein teil auf der arbeitsfläche
dünn ausrollen und damit es nicht kleben
bleibt mache ich es so dass ich da ein
bisschen back trend spray auf die
arbeitsfläche gebe also einfach so ein
bisschen fetten und dann mit einem
schönen nudelholz und zum austausch
statt einfach richtig schön rechteckig
ausbreiten den käse in die mitte legen
und dann umklappen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die fangen brote alle
soweit vorbereitet ich habe übrigens
beim käse einfach so ein gemisch
genommen dass ich glaube da hatte das
war and a la und dann hatte ich noch
geriebenen mozzarella da aber ihr könnt
gast nehmen worauf ihr lust habt und
jetzt habe ich hier noch butter einfach
in der mikrowelle zur last bei geringer
war zahle wird sie euch nicht platt und
da gebe ich jetzt noch probelauf mit
dazu ich bereite mir das jetzt einfach
vor damit ich die pfannen brote später
schön war mit dieser knoblauch butter
bestreichen kann und ich überlege mir
gleich noch ein bisschen petersilie fein
zu hacken weil ich finde dass ist immer
was grün ist noch mit dabei jetzt habe
ich hier eine gut beschichtete pfanne
und wenn er eine hat wo ihr denkt okay
das passt irgendwie immer an dann dürfte
ein bisschen fett das zugeben aber auch
am besten ist es wenn ihr die fanden
brotes komplett ohne fett von beiden
seiten schön auspackt weiß gar nicht wie
lange das brauche ich mache das immer
nach gefühl ich würde sagen pro seite ca
3 minuten aber ihr könnt auch schauen
dass die richtig schön goldbraun werden
dann könnte auch mal testweise dem
ersten aufmachen und reinschauen ich
mache das jetzt wie gesagt hier und
werde sie dann nach dem auspacken mit
meiner knoblauchbutter befinden sind
peter sie da oben drauf gehen und dann
brauche ich den hansa zum test
[Musik]
ich glaube dass es genau das für dich
eigentlich weiß ich sogar das ist genau
was für dich ist es gestern abend
gegessen ich glaub ich ein
großes brot auf der pfanne
wir sitzen also gestern abend von mir
das schöne geste zum himmel hin hatten
und muss sagen dass ich so was
ja
das ist richtig voll mit mozzarella und
empfahl das
hanse genießt richtig war ich gerade
voll und ich möchte mich noch da wollte
ich mich auch schon das ganze video über
seinen minen brot übernahme sind gemacht
man könnte auch joghurt nehmen braucht
dann aber mehr mail ist albert nahm dort
ist mit joghurt aber der rest ist kein
einfluss ich mir so ein traditionelles
brot machen willst dich ist nahm heißt
eigentlich brot grund für den konkurs
über die flügel
eigentlich waren wir ja keine boote
liegen jetzt einfach nur die ganze zeit
also um nach der kür und normal welcher
kann man auch so wenn man sich die
besucher und man hat keinen hehl
frikassee oder so und dann denkt man
sich bauer dann noch so ein verbot
nebenbei
also das zusammen als vorspeise nach dem
frühstück genauso frühstück einfach so
es geht einfach immer wieder mal fast
hätte das so betreten also ist das geil
ich das richtig erstmal hammer liebe das
einfach versuche das so zieht sich der
körper nach und nach machen und hat mir
gerne wieder auf vorschlägen in die
kommentare
dann wünschen wir euch noch einen
wunderschönen ja ich find's gut dass es
sich zu ähnlich ist ja es ist natürlich
ja aber wo ist doch völliger ist okay es
geht also noch einen wunderschönen tag
und bis zum nächsten mal frische skizze
[Musik]